Here we have the simple pulley--it's called a simple pulley because the rope goes from the rock
wounds over the pulley and right into the person's hand.
There's only one, let's call it connection point to the rock.
If we want to draw a force diagram for this rock as we are lifting,
we have the weight going downwards and that will be balanced by the tension, label T in the rope.
Remember in a rope, the tension is constant throughout.
So, what do you think what causes the tension in the rope? And this is a sort of subtle question.
There's a lot of things you could say or contributing tension in this rope.
But I want to know of these three options, what is the best answer?
Is the weight of this person, is it how hard this person is pulling,
or is it the normal force on the rock? Choose the best answer.